gross my name is Pippa welcome back to
The Last Guardian we ended up here in
front of this giant ass bridge and I
think I know where we're going we played
this part before anyone else by the way
it's very cool I appreciate that Sony
let me do that okay
he's so cute what is he looking
oh he's looking at us now hey how you
doing buddy hey welcome back to part
four great what we know so far is that
we're in the nest of this little guys
place we just woke up with him he just
happened to be here oh he's got a spear
in hand oh let's take it out I can't I
can't let that happen you have to
protect this little guy oh dude I'm
sorry I did it oh gee hey I'm sorry okay
okay okay hey hey hey calm down that's
it it's so cool it's not cool
ow should have broken every bone in my
body thing all right I think we have to
go here apparently these are called
man-eaters but ours is very nice for
some reason but it turns evil if ancient
technology turns on see I don't know
either what the hell is that it's all
about that's cool that you can walk
through there by the way I really think
that's awesome
hey poopie pie you're left without me
you [ __ ] oh oh you can cut what
that's so cool hey dude I can't [ __ ]
see it's this way - Jesus Christ he's
crazy well why don't you go ahead then
oh never mind you're too fat buddy okay
now okay we got butterflies here that
means there's candy oh yeah oh my god is
that drugs
[Music]
all right if you can open it you can
have it Neal I'm curious I was gonna do
with this Treecko
you got a treat for that while you're
doing great buddy
he doesn't know how to get it out um
well I don't [ __ ] know I don't look
at me like egg boats come on I'm hungry
okay we got three boxes I feel like
there's a puzzle here why are they three
I'm very confused
oh are you so cute okay let's see do can
we jump anywhere oh my god you clumsy
chilukula gecko so too busy because Tony
busy yeah who is that we had it on you
know you are on the true are you seein
easy it is noisy you know it again aah
oh really gettin enough ultra kono RTOG
Kino Tucker robust to native Ozzy into
the Kuna Oh is he okay so what's your
plan then oh my god it's so so now we
got commands I could use this I could
use this before but now I guess not so I
want him to get me up there move the boy
while holding our one-for-one whoa
that's cool he's listening come on
Treecko whoa jay says he broke the box
oh my god snacks everywhere oh my god I
love these
Oh Oh Don yo yo are the kitchen easy no
do you wanna see otra Kuno a cuneta
ultimate is easy art is a costume oh
cool nezzie Sacco on entry cool I'll go
down approach here you'll see Oh easy
it's so dumb though seriously let's go
this way
whoa he can attack he's so cool it's
really incredible how it works I can't
imagine what it'd be like to create an
AI in a game like this
there it is now we can jump up nice
thanks Treecko you're welcome buddy
any time call me okay so now we need to
[ __ ] I think I needed to go oh my god he
scares me still abaca so where do we go
how is he doing oh my god there's more
snacks nom nom nom okay I guess we're
fine to proceed not really what about
here oh here we go
okay cool okay well where'd you go boats
hey buddy I'm right here
don't you worry but I'm too fat it'd be
fun it'd be funny once you beat the game
you can play as Treecko I don't shitty
idea don't jump up just yet alright I'll
BRB there's always a way for oh my god
okay there's the butterfly here's the
lever
[Music]
what did that do I opened for it hey I
POTUS you good job
it's so cool dude you're not a cow
sorry how'd you like the impression
though alright I can jump on him that's
pretty [ __ ] cool I'm really enjoying
this now that yeah I can [ __ ] run with
him so he should be able to jump this
bridge right press while holding it to
jump okay this jump oh my god is so cool
Wow
yeah yeah Thank You Treecko you did you
did good you did good
good job oh I feel snakes you know that
was pretty easy but whatever ow
okay let's check what we got here then
since we managed to progress this place
is insane who built this
okay we got a giant s gate I don't know
how to get in there
well honestly I'm quite lost not
actually are we really supposed to go
here hey Treecko any ideas oh we can go
up there okay I see it now it's weird
it's hard to see like okay
got to keep climbing up on your way s
that way please
this okay you're really walking through
the [ __ ] wall right now maybe you
shouldn't do that
that's just like a thought yep you're
burning yourself dude
all right feels nice and hot what the
hell are you doing buddy now he's coming
for [ __ ] sake okay here we go stay
there it's there a stop command this is
what you want right yes it is just stand
oh my god just get me up there all right
come on just lift your neck up oh my god
where are you going now oh oh come on
that's a good boy good boy or girl
whatever you are thank you
what the hell I don't need to ah you
[ __ ]
go somewhere else what the [ __ ] is this
go up yeah dieter I know you can oh my
god oh my god puts I'm trying okay
it's always do this do that please for
the love of God there it is okay hey
almost there
[ __ ] you dude if you could only do this
a little further away then I just dab I
think I just dad oh no he's gonna sleep
now my god you're worse than Edgar oh
he's gonna do it now I have a great
feeling he's gonna do it he sees it
Treecko Treecko don't trick on me do not
go up against that wall
Treecko I swear to God but I love this
wall god damn it are you serious hey
while you're down there could you could
you slap my ass
come on pooch spank me spank me daddy
here we go all right now oh thank you
mine got that's it you did it oh my god
no don't [ __ ] this up don't [ __ ] stay
right there
are you ready to spank me finally Pierce
have you finally come to accept my
spanking okay here we go all right here
we go now we need to jump there don't
[ __ ] this up huh yes [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my
god
oh my god I did it thank God where's the
spank shut up okay just shut up here we
go then we're gonna go up here where
were we
yeah here whoa look at that
hey there's cool stuff down there this
is awesome so pretty oh god oh god oh
geez oh geez Louise I can climb here for
some reason and then maybe I can drop
down here no that's a terrible idea
why did you go where's my spanking maybe
I can go where do I go from here oh boy
do not look down okay all right oh my
god maybe I can go in that hole oh my
god that's so cool well this game is
making me anxious okay cool
we managed to progress six hours later
and we're in how do we got here uh I
don't know what this is
oh it's got an ominous feeling to it
jesus [ __ ] christ I'm insane I don't
think I was supposed to do that this is
cool then okay let's keep going
let's keep tip tap at Owen all right
yes I think we're doing we're doing okay
right so now go down here god damn this
is scare the [ __ ] out of me
all right there's a puzzle as a puzzle
to go down we could jump down there and
then we could go got it got it
not a problem oh there's spite there
there's the things down there they look
like a little like ocarina like those
little things that's it
Adsit Majora's Mask those deco things
okay
shut up all right but
look at that trick shotting there we go
let's go down oh my god then we go here
easy it's almost like someone put this
here
Oh nearly died that's fine
we're doing great Treecko is probably
wondering why it's no one expect him yet
but that's fine all right we got to be
real careful here real care these things
probably will do bad things if they find
you now let's [ __ ] hurry up
Treecko I need your help Hey you
promised me a spanking come on I'm
coming perch for the rescue I'm almost
there
oh hey everybody it's your boy he to the
PI no wait that's here oh god don't
that's it no one denies my spank
hey trinka doggie ugh
oh she know she called you - no go hey
drink the whole to the corner you I get
postman I don't get spanked you to
shooting up eat it up oh oh - it's
almost that stroking in different places
you can let's say to tell you the loozy
oh so cute I don't know what happened
I'm so [ __ ] okay now what I really
hope this game won't won't get a bunch
of flack because it's a little glitchy
like I can only imagine the technical
problems with the making a game like
this I really hope it doesn't because it
has so many great aspects to it and it
would be a shame to deny to deny this
game of its innovation and achievements
because of that okay all right I will I
will smack your ass when we're done with
this game oh that sounds good
that's a deal I know you can yes yes
thank you Trika your [ __ ] welcome you
know how hard that was all right
attitude please can we drop it
here we go I can see up your skirt when
you do that shut up shut up Jesus Christ
okay you got tiny nuts that's what I'm
trying to okay going in here now I don't
hear you
hey we're outside that's cool oh my god
um why do I go I think I know where oh
oh my god
well you shouldn't play this game if
you're scared of heights let that be
clear all right oh my god it's so
amazing I love this I think I can go up
now no he doesn't want to okay well you
know what I'm sorry I try to help there
should be a hole or something that I can
go in I hope at least otherwise dude my
hands are getting so sweaty from playing
this seriously seriously what do I go
well this is the end of the land
porty Park oh there's the hole oh my god
please hold on tight thank you
oh it makes me so anxious okay I'm back
be right back how to do my groceries no
wait one okay I'm high up now why um
well there's not many places for me to
go besides yeah
so I guess we'll go here breasts and
then we'll go oh there's more then we're
on the other side okay I get it I get it
God we just got to do the same thing
again without dying of course oh [ __ ]
which seems to be the problem here isn't
it okay
I climb up on this yep okay we got this
for a ChaCha's not a problem okay just
got to make sure you don't die that it's
a goal isn't it that would be ideal
alright dude don't be a [ __ ] I need you
to climb down hey
and but oh my god uh I can't take this
anymore yes that actually [ __ ] worked
oh my god
[ __ ] yeah suck it giuk just go down oh
my god oh my god oh my god well you've
done it now Pierce good job can they
even come down here though
I'm just going to wait and hope they
disappear hi guys
don't use ninjutsu powers alright that'd
be great
what did I say what did I [ __ ] say
stop oh my god while I'm really dead I
might as well
okay so they're kind of slow miss me
I'm coming trick oh god damn I hope they
don't get me this would be super
annoying
come on trick Oh for the love of God
hurry up
I'm coming purse ah no no drink Oh
dragged out oh stop it oh my god come on
come on come on come on no you're so
annoying no no no no no no no no hurry
up hurry up
Treecko you better be ready my man you
better be ready
I'm coming first just pull dammit you're
skinny [ __ ]
I'm Pauling come up come on drink oh
come on drink oh no no no no no no third
you can totally get in now
thank you hi I'm Sparta time
help me drink out laughs oh [ __ ] oh
thank you
now kick some ass that's right boy
that's [ __ ] right that's my boy
that's my dog that's my home done okay
I'm down bye okay hey buddy hey hey all
right all right
yes you're back I'm back I guess
all right finally one more chamber
probably that's it boy that's my boy
oh oh oh he's going for it okay well you
could have walked there you go come on
come on
thank you damn trick are you're getting
more responses every day you're awesome
I know all right be right back I gotta
open this gate for you
hey we're outside oh boy that's be
careful there we go yeah damn that [ __ ]
duck oh no it's a mirror oh oh we're
back okay
goddamnit Pierce you know I spanked me
he's still up there okay well I know he
hates mirrors so let's just get rid of
this ugly I said oh it's a gone is it
gone
yes I thank God it was so ugly remind me
of jacksepticeye's face why do I always
do that I'm sorry he's a beautiful man
this has to stop okay where do I go now
alright you got to put me up there buddy
ah [ __ ] I don't think this bridge is
safe
I don't trust bridges
not since Chad over there Colossus okay
that's it you know where to go he's
looking at it there you go use your tiny
wings and get me up there oh he's going
for it whoa dude you're [ __ ] crazy
that's awesome
ah I didn't click anything he just fell
off Jesus Christ
all right we're up here now Wow I don't
really know where to go and that looks
like it's it damn that's cool
that's really cool what's here they're
wrong you can't see it's too dark you
know I don't I don't think that was it
freaking oh my god you are one crazy man
Beast
okay Treecko whatever you do do not jump
away right now where are you looking oh
my god oh my god is he oh my god is he
oh my god okay all right that happened
what now oh [ __ ] you know where to go
this is [ __ ] cool man this is an epic
parkour [ __ ] oh my god
you nearly face-planted now what I want
to spank or else I'm not moving just do
another jump you can get me up there I'm
sure I can find a way to help you oh
he's doing something okay well well well
that did that didn't it oh my god
and credit all right I'll be going up
now thank you that was really good thank
you
hey we got butterflies okay this is
where the den was started I remember
this let's display this oh my god he's
coming with me I remember exactly how
you did this you got this is so hard as
a demo I really struggled
especially to jump up on this [ __ ]
thing why is that so hard I'm just gonna
do this really quick cuz I mean I've
you've probably already seen me play
this part I don't know maybe I can just
try and actually do it quick instead but
this took me a long ass [ __ ] time for
[ __ ] sake jump up oh my god there you
go up here I wonder if anything changed
pull the lever which will open the gates
downstairs I lit the flame what did that
flame do I forgot [ __ ] I don't know all
right I'm gonna jump on you oh never
mind okay I guess I have to walk down so
he goes okay so he sees the light he
wants to go to the line and then uh and
then
he needs to come down you need to come
down oh my god stop playing with that
thing Jay says this way that's it come
on
yes yes yes yes yes ah oh oh my god oh
my god okay we're alive that's it get
the juice pick up the juice I remember
now
then walk with Allah he carries it so
cool grandmas favorite she loves this
[ __ ] alright
bombs away or chopped Treecko nice toss
and then Treecko
watch your face nailed it so much detail
in everything in this so amazing okay
now let's just hang the punt as you do
now
he's gonna pull it up oh my god
Oh oh boy
then I remember this one out don't die I
love this new toy you got me pear thank
you so much
hey man you're welcome would be great if
you just work with me oh my god what am
i doing oh my god
ah come on no ignore me ignore me
Treecko go play
oh he's gonna try and jump up oh my god
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] were you
thinking
go play with your toy thank [ __ ] god
keep pulling keep goddamnit there it is
ah finally
whew you want this yes yes yes come get
nice now let's go it's safe I tested it
there you go
good dog I mean Treecko what the [ __ ]
did you call me excuse me I'm a chicken
cat dog fish don't assume my gender oh
my god I'm standing on his nose oh here
we go
alright
there's those things we have to get rid
of them I'm scared of them it's so cute
I got you
oh don't worry like we are you made him
are you no clue see you too Oh Oh Richie
one bum yeah kiss aw why is he so scared
of them I'm really curious about story
well what is going on at least I have no
idea if you have theories posting in the
comments
flying that said your brooch net here we
go good
Wow look it is so beautiful I love this
part okay so now we can jump off oh god
oh god ow
we're fine hello your walks downstairs
they animation oh my god everything is
so [ __ ] cool
alright so Oh
Treecko I'm coming I'm coming to save
you I remember this part we got to be
real fast
Oh God
oh my god okay now help me up please
now please hey you try kill me
give me your tail or something what the
[ __ ] do you want me to do buddy oh boy
he's doing something he just did a jump
see I jumped what else do you want okay
he's doing something now
Jesus Christ oh my god alright now we
got to wait for him to save me now
remember it's so cool this part is
amazing okay he's ready for me oh it's
so cool oh my god don't eat me face I'm
glad he got my shirt and not my [ __ ]
face thank you you're welcome Poots I
saved your life
now we just got to get rid of this okay
just go down ow
okay now we're just gonna this one
who built these and why keep them away
right now I definitely oh I get it go
down
okay oh we got to hurry up oh my god
these slow-mo motions I can't I forgot
about this ah the tan
look at that hurry up Treecko
yeah just run just fine thank you
oh my god
I'm climbing up now we got to climb up
and help oh my god
have a drink
what's the problem that's stopping you
yeah right
stupid pot Oh God oh oh come on
hey you go is gone
climb where
right
there it is okay finally nice hell yeah
trickle and PayPal photo app that was
easy
Jesus Christ okay perfect time to end
this episode here
I'm loving playing this game for your
breath so I really appreciate that you
live it like if you're enjoying it as
well and I'll see you tomorrow with
another pipe thanks for watching stay
awesome bris
[Music]